so picture this you're streaming on
twitch hanging out with your Chad and
just doing your thing but then you
receive a 24 hour ban and when you look
into why it's literally because of
something that happened a year ago this
is exactly what happened to to twitch
streamers earlier this week and yeah
it's kind of funny you know this is
[ __ ] ridiculous kind of way but these
retroactive punishments are really
dangerous let me tell you why okay so
earlier this week - pretty big twitch
streamers learn in angels Kimmie
received copyright strikes for playing
the song work by Bazzi at some point on
stream but here's the deal these things
happened in September in October of 2018
and the crazy thing about learned
situation is that she wasn't even
playing the song on stream but she ran
into some random in pub GE who had his
proximity chat turned on okay so to be
clear learn received her copyright
strike in 24 hour ban because somebody
else was playing music not her and in
the case of Kimmy twitch actually
reached out to her and stated that it
was the record company that hit her with
the strike and not twitch but here's the
thing
twitch passing the blame is part of the
problem because it seems like every week
we're hearing more and more news about
people receiving copyright strikes
content creators are constantly getting
banned or having their content taken
down not because they're explicitly
breaking any rules but because we don't
even know what the [ __ ] rules are
sometimes when can you play music is
there a volume threshold or certain
songs and labels off-limits it's not
like twitch has a streaming orientation
day where they sit down every
fifteen-year-old kid hand them a
sandwich and explain what they can and
can't do on the platform now when their
Terms of Service
twitch does talk about what you can and
can't do with music but the problem is
the way that these punishments are
handed out to content creators is
seemingly random and inconsistent and
the scary part is is with these
independent content creators this [ __ ]
can jeopardize their livelihood and cost
them money how difficult would it be for
twitch to make a decision to say just
ban music outright I know it's an
extreme example but then at the very
least it would clear up a lot of the
confusion that we've been seeing over
the past months okay so I've been
talking a lot about copyright strikes in
the last couple of minutes but let's be
super clear and what that actually means
okay so it starts with something called
the DMCA or the Digital Millennium
Copyright Act which was created in 1998
this basically allows platforms like
Google Facebook and twitch to say hey we
just provide the infrastructure and we
have nothing to do with the content
stopping publishing companies from suing
those platforms directly in this way it
does make sense when twitch says hey
it's not us who has a problem with you
playing music it's the recording company
and as for copyright strikes well those
are a platform specific policy and
YouTube does it differently than twitch
does who does it differently than
Twitter it's considered a way to police
content creators who use large chunks of
content that belong to someone else
which in this case is music it's why
sometimes when you watch a twitch bought
from your favorite streamer some of the
audio might be cut out or the video is
removed entirely now copyright laws get
really complicated and I don't have a
[ __ ] law degree or the time to
explain the intricacies of US law in a
10 minute video so let's move on now
let's say you and I go toe-to-toe on
bird law and see who comes out to
victory you know I don't think I'm gonna
do anything close to that anyway even if
learn
kymmie did violate twitches tos when it
comes to copyrighted material it's
absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous that
they're receiving these random copyright
strikes a full year later because here's
the thing on twitch if you receive three
copyright strikes that's it your entire
audience in the account that you've
built over years is Dawne so I like two
out of three strikes my third strike I'm
kicked out of the game and then I'm just
permaban
and it begs the question what do you do
when you come in for work every day and
the rules are different it's easy just
to say don't play any copyrighted music
whatsoever but what if you're just a 15
year old kid mimicking some of the
biggest streamers in the world with
streaming now being a viable career for
almost anybody it is super important
that these rules are consistent for
everyone on top of all that you can get
a copyright strike from another creator
like in the case of the keemstar pokey
main Fiasco from earlier this year
because we've all seen people on Twitch
reacting to youtube videos and guess
what that's grounds for a copyright
strike and look I don't have all the
answers I'm just a dude who thinks it's
[ __ ] up that I have to hear about this
type of thing every single week
especially in the case of learn who
objectively did nothing wrong
twitch needs to take a stronger stance
on this because at best this fence
sitting hands-off approach is a
confusing mess and then it's very worst
people can have their entire careers
taken away from them because what they
wanted to listen to some music and hang
out with some friends on stream
I was the dude who's tired about hearing
about this [ __ ] yeah I understood
doo doo hoo I'm just a dude who thinks
[ __ ] you sons of [ __ ] on
[Applause]